thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air by clicking the
link in the description you'll also get
nebula for free streaming platform made
by and for creators like me
the time is the roaring 20s the place
the glamorous downtown streets of
Chicago gangsters and bootleggers
capture most of the headlines in the
attention of police clubs overflow with
the young the beautiful and the
rebellious there's too much jazz and
never enough gin but then a strange and
horrible event shakes the city from its
euphoria in fact the whole world is
rocked by a deadly crime spree pulled
off by two of the wealthiest and most
promising young men in the city
a pair of rich geniuses brutally murder
a boy for their own callous amusement in
intellectual curiosity the victim Bobby
Franks only age fourteen news that an
innocent boy has been killed in cold
blood as part of a twisted experiment
sweeps across the country like wildfire
America speculates in a frenzy what
could have driven these two rich
gentlemen to murder for fun plagued by a
dark psychosis that no one detected the
young scholars prodigies arrogantly
explained their heartless plan the
killer's Nathan Leopold and Richard Loeb
does anyone who kills for a twisted
ideology have grounds for anything less
than the harshest sentence that's the
question that we have to face in the
cases of Leopold and Loeb the genius
murderers
we present for your adjudication young
Nathan Leopold age 19 undeniably a
genius his IQ is in the top 2% of those
tested at this time though he didn't
speak his first words until age 4 he now
speaks 15 languages and he has just
graduated from the University of Chicago
with Phi Beta Kappa honors he's charming
the envy of younger boys and suitor to a
stunning young woman of impeccable
breeding Leopold is dashing and
brilliant he believes the world as his
for the taking and his accomplice
Richard Loeb age 18
another prodigy after becoming the
youngest graduate from the University of
Michigan at the age of 17 Loeb is
currently working on his graduate
studies at the University of Chicago
despite his impressive school record
Loeb is not excited by intellectual
pursuits he'd rather be playing tennis
or reading detective stories like most
teenage boys Loeb loves the puzzle
solving challenge of crime novels so Eve
reads a lot of books in which the bad
guy holiest gets caught these two rising
stars collide in the early 1920s
although Leopold and Loeb know each
other as children they become close
during their time at the University of
Chicago where their genius intellects
set them apart from the rest of the
student body they decide to find their
own interests and ventures ones that
appeal to their inflated sense of
self-worth Leopold and Loeb had
separately been lauded as prodigies
since they were toddlers together they
come to believe that they are truly
superior to nearly everyone else in fact
99% of society so when they read the
works of German philosopher Nietzsche
they seize upon his idea of the Superman
a transcendent individual who possesses
extraordinary and unusual capabilities
which makes them above the laws that
bind normal society
this philosophy further warps the minds
of our two young scholars Leopold
entranced by the idea that he and Loeb
are so extraordinary that different
rules apply to them urges his friend to
adopt the same beliefs
riding a Superman is on account of
certain superior qualities inherent in
him exempted from the ordinary laws
which govern men he's not liable for
anything he may do Loeb needs little
convincing
the duo sets out to commit a string of
crimes and they get away with all but
the criminal scholars decide to push
this Nietzschean theory even further
they resolved to aim higher not arson or
battery no this time they plan a murder
one so cold and callous it will become
one of the most read and studied legal
cases of all time in short they set out
to commit the perfect crime one that is
the psychotic buddies believe they can
pull off with complete immunity in 1929
Leopold and Loeb begin preparations for
the killing a plan that begins with the
already heinous crime of kidnapping
because the two resolved to murder an
innocent child they first must decide
how the abduction will take place should
they take the boy from his bedroom in
the middle of the night perhaps steal
him away from his family while they're
out on the town they then begin
contemplating the murder itself how
should we kill him they ask poison
shooting
stabbing they coldly discuss one
gruesome idea after another before at
last settling on a method for these evil
geniuses there are still more
preparations to make another part of
their diabolical plan involves typing a
ransom note from a fake person in
creating a bank account in a false name
into which the victims family can
deposit the ransom money dispassionately
they discuss renting a car and typing
the ransom demand on a typewriter the
lobe steals from his own fraternity
house the pair plot and complete each
villainous step seemingly failing to
realize that each one exposes them to
more eyewitnesses the two demented
prodigies spend 7 months making their
murderous plans at last on May 21st 1924
on a warm and cloudless spring day
Leopold and Loeb put their long plotted
gruesome plan into action
first they lure fourteen-year-old Bobby
Frank's a trusting neighbor tennis buddy
and second cousin of lobes to the rental
car
the charming killers whom Bobby knows
and looks up to convince him to come to
their car to discuss a new tennis racket
that Loeb has been using they then sees
him binds him and speed away
the kidnapping has begun after the
madmen have Bobby in the car the
horrific deed moves into full swing as
Leopold drives Logue repeatedly hits
Bobby in the head with a metal chisel
then drags him into the back seat where
the dreadful undertaking continues in
the back seat Loeb gags young Bobby with
his own hands covering Bobby's nose and
face until the ill-fated child can no
longer breathe and at last suffocates
now traveling with their victim's body
the depraved men drive on to their
predetermined dumping site 25 miles
south of Chicago in Indiana for the
entire trip
Bobby lies hidden beneath a robe the
brutal murder has no effect on these two
monsters in fact they grab a bite to eat
on their way to dispose of the poor boys
remains shockingly they even eat in the
car with the corpse as they drive along
after sundown they heartlessly stripped
Bobby of his clothes and dragged his
lifeless body to a culvert
near some railroad tracks lo keeps a
lookout while Leopold carefully removes
his own coat and shoes and then Don's a
pair of boots to take the remains into
the sewer canal to try to prevent
Bobby's identification in a grizzly act
Leopold pours - lauric acid on his face
and body finally he covers Bobby with a
robe once more Leopold emerges from the
tunnel confident that his work has been
meticulous but unbeknownst to either of
the killers Leopold's glasses are left
at the dumping site their twisted sense
of superiority prevents them from ever
considering the possibility of human
hair feeling secure in their grisly
endeavors so far they duck back into
their blood-stained rental car and head
back to Chicago but unnoticed by the
murderers eyewitnesses continue to
accumulate on their drive back north a
woman and her daughter are on their way
home from a picture show since the road
is dark the mother flashes her brights
when approaching Leopold and Loeb zkk
are coming from the other
action the ladies get a clear look at
the car passing them it's around 9:30
p.m. next Leopold stops at a drugstore
to call his girlfriend in his home
claiming that he's still nearby an out
with friends he tells them he'll be a
little later getting back and in turn
his parents remind him that he must
drive his aunt home upon his return
Leopold hopes these conversations will
support an alibi but of course phone
calls are no such proof finally back in
Chicago the nefarious pair begin to
dispose of the evidence
they stopped at Loubs home where Loeb
burns Bobby's clothes in the furnace
meanwhile in the garage Leopold attempts
to clean Bobby's bloodstains from the
rental cars front seat thinking the
large road may cause too much smoke in
the furnace the two decide to hide it in
the ardent plan to burn it later still
feeling pleased with the execution of
their plan Loeb stays with Leopold's
family at their house while Leopold at
last drives his aunt home but their
terrible business on this fateful night
is not done yet and around 10:30 p.m.
before returning home
Leopold calls Bobby's parents pretending
to be the man named George Johnson
Bobby's unsuspecting mother answers the
call and receives news that throws her
life into a living nightmare lying
Leopold tells mrs. Franks and her son
Bobby I'm trapped but is unharmed
he orders mrs. Frank's to wait for
further instructions regarding the
$10,000 ransom he warns her that she and
her husband must strictly follow his
directions and that they cannot contact
the police
once Leopold arrives home he and Loeb
settled down to wait and play cards for
a while around 1:00 o'clock in the
morning the two leave in the rental car
to mail their ransom note dropping it
off for special delivery to the Franks
on the way back to Loubs house Loeb
tosses the chisel into some brush along
the roadside Leopold drops off low but
around 1:40 a.m. and heads back home as
their bloody crimes draw to a close but
the Frank's nightmare is far from over
the next day the ransom demand arrives
around noon which mrs. Frank's can
barely open because her hands are
shaking so badly
currently the Franks try to understand
the letters instructions they must wait
at their home for another call at 1
o'clock p.m. which will tell them where
to leave the money the letter is signed
George Johnson and concludes remember
that this is your only chance to recover
your son but at these very moments the
police are already unraveling Leopold
and Loeb quote perfect crime their first
mistake the chisel that lobed threw out
into the brush a man who was watching
curiously decided to see what had been
tossed from the window of their fancy
rental car in the middle of the night he
was shocked to find the bloody chisel
and by 2:30 a.m. that eyewitness has
turned the murder weapon over to police
the two self-proclaimed geniuses having
an inkling that tangible evidence
against them is already being collected
mere hours later to early morning
workmen happen across Bobby's remains
where they also find Leopold's
spectacles they gently remove the boy's
body from the culvert and contact police
when the police arrived they also find
one of Bobby Franks socks by late
morning Leopold and Loeb are scrubbing
the carpet in the rear of the car
Leopold's chauffeur happens upon them
and Leopold clumsily invents a story
they spilled some red wine in the car
and they're cleaning it out so Loubs
father won't see it this might make
sense but this is not lobes car at 2:00
p.m. an hour after the Franks expect
more instructions
Leopold drops off Loeb at the train
station where Loeb buys a train ticket
in his own name for Michigan City
he quickly boards the car and deposits a
letter in the train's telegraph rack the
criminal masterminds hoped to trick
authorities into believing that Loeb was
on the train at the very time the Franks
are due to be contacted in Chicago
meanwhile Leopold doesn't waste any time
while Loeb is planting the letters on
the train Leopold goes to a drugstore
and calls the francs instructing them to
go to a different drugstore and wait
there for another call Leopold gives the
francs the designated address and hangs
up then hurries back to pick up Loeb
from the train station once together
again
the naive perpetrators go back to the
drugstore near the station to call the
other drugstore where they believe the
francs are anxiously waiting
but by now Bobby's body has already been
identified by his uncle and is in the
county morgue remarkably just five
minutes before Leopold called the Franks
the police arrived to give them the life
shattering news that their poor little
boy is dead of course
the Franks are not going to any
drugstore at this plan before the day is
out much to the deranged men's chagrin
Bobby's death is already in the
newspapers with Bobby dead how can they
pull off a ransom payday now in a panic
Loeb urges Leopold to call everything
off but Leopold stubbornly disagrees
racking his brilliant mind for a way to
still get the money but failing to come
up with anything Leopold agrees the new
plan is to plant evidence to make it
look like someone else murdered Bobby
once the two get rid of their rental car
they decide to try to pin the murder on
one George Louis the ornithology student
in one of the zoology classes Leopold
teaches Leopold's genius ideas to frame
one of his bird enthusiast students
because some of them frequent the part
of Indiana where Bobby's remains were
found
Leopold doesn't even consider that Luis
may have a rock-solid alibi how could
two geniuses be so birdbrain the two
were acting in a blind panic now they're
smug intelligence proving the crumbling
facade as the net closes in driving with
no consideration for the speed limit
Leopold picks up Loeb they retrieve
Bobby's Road from the backyard and drive
to a secluded spot they burn it on the
side of the road out of anyone's sight
as far as they know they then speed to
Indiana where they hide Bobby's clasp in
belt buckle and shoes but before they
can finish their cover a plan captain
Wolf of the Chicago Police Department
calls Leopold in for questioning much to
the surprise of the dastardly pair
though worried about the execution of
their frame-up they still don't know how
close the police really are captain
Wolf's ass Leopold about his neighbor
Bobby Franks and asks where Leopold saw
him last
after wolf tells Leopold about Bobby's
grim fate Leopold offers his flimsy
alibi and implicates innocent George
Louis saying he is known to frequent the
sight of Indiana where Bobby's body was
found
clearly Leopold hopes to plant a red
herring but this bird expert has no way
of knowing that
fish wouldn't swim as soon as the
captain finishes speaking with leopold
leopoldovich mmediately drive to a park
where Loeb heard Lee twists the keys off
the typewriter used to write the ransom
note they throw the keys in the
typewriter into a lagoon but their
efforts are in vain by this point the
police have already been collecting
evidence and witnesses against the
nefarious duo for the last 10 hours the
most damning evidence
Leopold's forgotten glasses the police
follow one clue after another for six
days identifying the glasses owner was
simple mr. ko the owner of an eyewear
shop immediately recognizes the glasses
is one of a rare design ko tells the
police only three customers on that set
and one of them is Leopold by May 28th
the police have spent almost a week
tracking down leads collecting clues
gathering tangible proof and creating a
long list of eyewitnesses at this point
they decide it's time to hear whatever
fantastic story Leopold and Loeb have
come up with the police questioned the
self-proclaimed geniuses separately
hoping to get a confession to support
the mountain of evidence already in the
laws possession the questions take place
at a local hotel in the hopes of making
the criminals feel more comfortable and
more likely to sing Leopold continues to
offer the police names of other possible
suspects he then gives two conflicting
answers about where his spectacles might
be Loeb on the other hand tries to claim
he doesn't remember what happened hoping
to avoid making any truly damning
mistakes both give police their flimsy
false alibis but Leopold is too reckless
and even admits if I were to murder
anybody it would be just such a cocky
little son of a [ __ ] Bobby Franks the
police released the men for the night
but secretly have them followed finally
around 1:00 a.m. on May 30th Leopold and
Loeb are arrested for the murder of
Bobby Franks once at the station for
processing the police give the two some
details about the mountain of evidence
stacked against them Loeb is the first
to break and start confessing and when
Leopold finds out he confesses to
finally the Franks are on their way to
some justice for their little boy
but it turns out that the path to
justice is a truly twisted Road Leopold
and Loeb families hire the most famous
lawyer in the world Clarence Darrow of
the Scopes Monkey Trial Fame and they
pay him a $70,000 retainer which was a
fortune and would be over a million
dollars today billed as the trial of the
century this is in every way the
predecessor to the OJ Simpson case but
given the grisly facts of the trial why
would the most famous lawyer in the
world take the case because he was
staunchly against the death penalty
Darrow famously opposed capital
punishment throughout his career but the
facts are not in dispute two brilliant
young minds decided to kill a young boy
just to see if they could complete the
perfect crime the killers confessed
Darrow knows that if Leopold and Loeb
plead not guilty they will be convicted
by a jury and sentenced to death
even the greatest lawyer in the world
can only do so much so Darrow's astute
legal mind comes up with a tactic that
might at least save their twisted lives
Darrow suggests that the pair skipped
the trial and focused exclusively on
sentencing on the day of the indictment
the town is in a tizzy and people all
over the country want to know how these
two calculating child killers will flee
what could they possibly say to defend
themselves let's go to the courtroom
where the opposing lawyers are about to
square off in a courtroom jammed with
people but so silent you could hear a
pin drop mr. Darrow
how do your clients plead to the counts
of kidnapping and first-degree murder
guilty the courtroom is full of shocked
gasps and murmurs but once it's quiet
again Darrow simply requests a full
hearing on sentencing before the court
decides on the killers penalty the court
grants his requests so in Illinois is
pleading guilty enough to avoid the
death penalty for first-degree murder in
kidnapping
the state's attorney Robert crow is
certain that this will be a hanging case
however there's the Darrow factor and
Darrow is even smarter than the two men
he's defending Darrow is aware that a
plea of insanity would be futile the
facts are known and at this point in his
career the only client that Clarence
Darrow ever lost to execution tried the
insanity defense and failed miserably so
Darrow takes a different more audacious
route sending the case into an
unbelievable 32 day hearing on
sentencing alone will Darrow be able to
convince the court that life sentences
are sufficient or will these two
sociopaths hang for their terrible crime
let's see what the Cook County Court
decided in September of 1924 we take you
to the courthouse where the historic
sentencing is about to begin
good morning I'd like to first express
that while this case has attracted a lot
of attention in the community at large I
will not allow this courtroom to become
a circus we are here only to resolve the
matter of sentencing is the state ready
to proceed yes your honor
Robert crow for the people of the state
of Illinois Council for defendants yes
judge Clarence Darrow on behalf of
Nathan Leopold and Richard Loeb all
right then mr. crow you may begin
thank you and may it please the court
Your Honor these defendants are nothing
less than depraved hyper sociopaths who
think nothing of human life if ever a
case for the death penalty existed it is
this one
these men admitted that they planned and
committed the gruesome murder of a young
boy an innocent child who presented no
threat because they thought it would be
a fun experiment
moreover they both stated that this
heinous act was thrilling and mr.
Leopold has admitted that he had an
interest in learning what it would be
like to murder a human being
objection your honor counsel is offering
evidence not in the record as there was
no trial in which my clients testified
under oath
objection sustained be careful mr. crow
proceed are the defendants sick yes but
not from any mental illness but instead
a knowingly embraced depravity I
hesitate to even call them men
as true men would never do or even
consider such violence toward a poor
child I urge the court to consider to
the endless anguish in which Bobby's
parents will have to live for the rest
of their lives
capital punishment was made for just
such a case your argument mr. Darrow
Your Honor it has been said that we pled
guilty because we are afraid to do
anything else that is true we seek mercy
but not exoneration and we have said to
the public and to this court that
neither the parents nor the friends nor
the attorneys of these boys would want
them released unfortunate though it may
be it is true and those the closest to
them know perfectly well that they
should not be released and that they
should be permanently isolated from
society we are only asking this court to
save their lives and the key question in
this case is not whether my clients did
something horrific but rather whether
there were circumstances that mitigate
their level of personal responsibility
despite counsels attempt to paint Nathan
and Richard as inhuman they certainly
are not
they are young men whose minds have been
and are still being molded by the world
around them as well as by the smaller
environment in which they live out every
day of their lives
their parents homes their college
classes their sports practices and the
like and these smaller worlds which are
intimate to my clients must be closely
examined before deciding on a fair and
just penalty for their crimes the state
may proceed with argument over 100
witnesses for the state testified to the
countless lies attempts to implicate
innocent people and path of destruction
left behind by these two ghouls that
evidence combined with the hard tangible
evidence is enough to warn death for
these two abhorrent defendants mr.
Darrow did you want to comment on
witness or evidence yes thank you judge
as the court is seen we produced many
witnesses for the court including
psychiatric experts and those
individuals closest to and familiar with
the daily lives of Nathan and rich
they're reliable testimony and other
evidence has shown that my clients are
not deserving of death mr. Crowe please
advise the court of the state's
recommendation for sentencing
the state is recommending death by
hanging for both of the defendants
Leopold and Loeb are highly educated and
they were raised by kind and civilized
members of society therefore they were
well aware that life is valued and that
it is against the law in every state of
the Union to murder an innocent person
furthermore they soberly planned and
brutally executed the murder of an
innocent 14 year old boy leaving two
parents to grieve and profoundly suffer
for the rest of their lives execution is
the only fair and just sentence thank
you
mr. Darrow your position for the record
please your honor what is the law of
Illinois if one is found guilty of
murder in the first degree by a jury or
if he pleads guilty before a court the
court or jury may do one of three things
he may hang he may imprison for life or
he may imprison for a term of not less
than 14 years now why is that the law
does it follow from the statute that a
court is bound to ascertain the
impossible and must necessarily measure
the degrees of guilt not at all he may
not be able to do it a court may act
from any reason or from no reason a jury
may fix any one of these penalties as
they separate the defendants plead for
life in prison over the death sentence
thank you mr. Darrow the state's
position is well known please proceed
with your case for life rather than
death this terrible crime judge was in
born in their very nature handed down
from ancestry could any young student be
blamed because he took Nietzsche's
philosophies seriously and fashioned his
life upon them now Your Honor we must
also talk of the Great War for four long
years the civilized world was engaged in
killing men by the thousands do you
suppose this world has ever been the
same since we've Randolph killing one
hundred thousand men in a day these boys
were brought up in such an environment
the tales of death were in their homes
their playground
their schools they learn to place a
cheap value on human life mr. crow does
the state have any evidence to refute
mr. Darrow's point regarding the effects
of war on the minds of children and
their value of life
of course the state offers simple
common-sense look at the thousands of
children the same age as the defendants
who also live through the tragic days of
war they haven't killed anyone and if
I'm unaware of one or more who have and
it's still evidence that mr. Darrow's
argument does not hold one your honor
knows that in this very Court crimes of
violence have increased since the war
not necessarily by those who fought but
by those who learned that blood was
cheap and human life was cheap if the
state and our country could take these
lives lightly why not young boys there
are causes for this crime war is part of
it education is part of it birth is part
of it money is part of it
all these conspired to encompass the
destruction of these two poor boys
if the welfare of the community would be
benefited by taking these lives well and
good I however think it would work a
greater evil that no one could measure
all murders have a cause why did they
kill little Bobby Franks they killed him
as they might kill a spider or a fly for
the experience the killed him because
they were made that way because
somewhere in the infinite processes that
go into the making up of the boy or the
man something slipped and those
unfortunate lads sit there hated
despised outcasts with the community
shouting for their blood may I respond
to mr. garrow's last arguments please go
ahead without getting into specific
details suffice to say the collection of
testimony from over 100 of the state's
witnesses is from reliable people whose
accounts are all consistent and most
importantly demonstrated coldness and
even enjoyment on the part of the
defendants during every step of their
planning execution and post murder to
seep 'full actions Thank You mr. crow
mr. Darrow you may continue
have been sorry and I'm sorry for the
bereavement of mr. and mrs. Frank's for
all those broken ties that cannot be
healed all I can hope and wish is that
some good may come from it all I know
the boys are not fit to be at large the
easy thing and the popular thing to do
would be to hang my clients the cruel
and thoughtless will approve
be careful mr. Darrow this Court does
not make decisions based on what's
popular it answers only to the laws on
the books I intend no disrespect your
honor but in Chicago and reaching over
the length and breadth of the land more
and more fathers and mothers the humane
the kind the hopeful will join in no
acclaim at the death of my clients they
would ask that the shedding of blood be
stopped and that the normal feelings of
men resumed their sway 90 poor
unfortunate men have given up their
lives to stop murder in Chicago 90 men
have been hanged by the neck until dead
because of the ancient superstition that
in some way hanging one man keeps
another from committing a crime and that
the only way to treat crime is to
intimidate everyone into goodness and
obedience to law I am pleading for life
understanding charity kindness and
infinite mercy that considers all I'm
pleading that we overcome cruelty with
kindness and hatred with love you may
hang them by the neck until they're dead
but in doing so you would turn your face
toward the past in doing it you would be
making it harder for every other boy who
in ignorance and darkness must grope his
way through the mazes which only
childhood knows if your honor can hang a
boy at 18 some other judge can hang him
at 17 or 16 or 14 some day if there is
any such thing as progress in the world
if there is any spirit of humanity that
is working in the hearts of men some day
men would look back on this as a
barbarous age which deliberately set
itself in the way of progress humanity
and sympathy and committed an
unforgivable act mr. crow
tell me how death will better serve
society than will life in prison as you
said yourself judge this court must
answer to the laws
on the books this case falls squarely
under the law which provides for death
by hanging we cannot allow the public to
believe that our laws are meaningless so
it's imperative that this court abides
by the law to its letter furthermore
death by hanging will work as a logical
deterrent most people who realize that
they could be hanged for murder will opt
against committing such a heinous crime
some people may still kill if they know
they may only spend part of their life
in prison with a strong chance of parole
for good behavior for example when
Leopold and Loeb murdered little Bobby
Franks they breached the social contract
that binds us all together
their lives were forfeit the moment they
took Bobby's hanging these men may not
bring Bobby back but retributive justice
demands that they suffer and if their
deaths prevent the loss of even one
innocent life it will have been worth it
mr. Darrow a brief closing please we
have placed our fate in the hands of
this learned Court knowing that it would
be more mindful and considerate than a
jury it is my only hope that we may all
temper justice with mercy and overcome
hatred with love thank you so what are
your thoughts if you were judge Caverly
what would you decide should these
brilliant but depraved young men with
luxurious but less than ideal childhoods
escape the gallows put your proposed
verdict in the comments how do you think
it came out Clarence Darrow sentencing
argument is the stuff of legal legend he
went on for over 12 hours and 20
thousand words
commentators called it the greatest
speech of his career in the most
eloquent argument against the death
penalty ever given judge Caverly handed
down his decision on September 10th 1924
as the entire country waited with bated
breath the sentence for the murder and
kidnapping convictions of both Nathan
Leopold and Richard Loeb was an order of
life imprisonment plus 99 years they
were spared the gallows and what
happened to Leopold and Loeb themselves
well they went to jail for a very long
I'm Loeb was killed in jail 12 years
later by a fellow inmate Leopold served
out the rest of his sentence and was
paroled 33 years later in 1958 he
eventually moved to Puerto Rico studied
wildlife and died of a heart attack at
the age of 66 the mission of this
channel is to demystify the law and that
can be hard on YouTube when you're
dealing with sensitive subjects like
this video because the only thing
scarier than murder is getting
demonetised which is why my creator
friends and I teamed up to build our own
platform where creators don't have to
worry about D monetization or the
dreaded algorithm it's called nebula and
we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity Street Nebula is a place where
creators can do what they do best create
it's a place where we can both house our
content at free and also experiment with
new original series that probably
wouldn't work on YouTube in fact if you
liked this episode of the case of you
can find an extended version that I
actually can't show on YouTube it's
legal eagle but now with 10% more murder
and when I say that nebula is built by
creators for creators I mean it Nebula
features lots of YouTube's top
educational creators like knowing better
h-bomb or guy real engineering tier zoo
and tons of others we also get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on YouTube for example the nebula
exclusive series called working titles
where every episode a different creator
breaks down their favorite TV intro
sequence polyphonic did Game of Thrones
Patrick Williams did x-men and I'll be
covering Law & Order really soon
[Music]
seriously we worked really hard on this
and we're really proud of the result the
project is self-funded we're not backed
by investors and we've managed to make
all of this add three with no dreaded
algorithm so where does curiosity stream
come in all this well they love
educational content and educational
creators so they were the perfect
partner for nebula we just recently
worked out a deal where if you sign up
your curiosity stream with a link in the
description not only will you get one
free month of curiosity stream but
you'll also get a nebula subscription
for free and to be clear that nebula
subscription is not a trial if you
decide to sign up with curiosity stream
long term you'll get nebula as long as
you're here
ASSA tea stream member so that means
that for less than 20 bucks a year not
only do you get unlimited access to
curiosity streams massive library of
gorgeous high budget documentaries
you'll also enjoy the private playground
of YouTube's best educational creators
for no additional charge and you'll be
supporting creators like me directly
just go to curiosity stream comm slash
league legal or click the link in the
description and if you sign up using the
link below it'll take you directly to
one of my favorite curiosity stream
documentaries Peter sagal 'he's history
which explains how some of the most
pivotal events in US history are tied to
money including Watergate and the Civil
War it's right there on the website so
click on the link in the description to
get a free month of both curiosity
stream and nebula or sign up for less
than three dollars a month or less than
$20 per year you can support creators
and education at the same time and
finally back to Leopold and Loeb is it
fair that they were able to avoid being
hanged is the death penalty really a
deterrent or is it just a blight on
civil society what do you think leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here where
you can see all of the episodes of the
case of including my favorite the cases
of the shotgun booby trap check out this
playlist and I'll see you in court